hi I'm Ben Hubbard I'm
video services and special events at UC
berkeley i'm also the
cast program with my colleague over
there Adam hopeman I work for
educational technology services and I
wanted to start by telling you a little
bit about our organization we're
comprised of several different subunits
the learning systems group which works
on the B space and the Sakai initiative
there and there were a developing
partner in the sky initiative and they
also do a lot of teaching and learning
activities with faculty training program
that sort of thing I'm part of the what
we kind of term is learning spaces group
I'm work in the classroom technology and
special events group there at UC
Berkeley and we also have a design and
engineering group which manages the
classroom installations of all of our
technology projectors and DVD players
and VHS decks so I wanted to start by
saying that organizationally it's it's
really we're really set up well to
tackle a lot of the video delivery
issues that stem from a desire to
provide a window into the educational
resources of our institution and you
know we just have an amazing collection
of technical expertise and experience
under our belt we've got a lot of
developers and programmers and great
project management and AV experience
that we've been able to have under this
sort of single umbrella single vision
and leadership towards providing that
window so it's really been helpful to
have those those ties underneath their
own organization and not have to make
those connections across different units
within the university because that's
always a little bit more difficult road
to hoe
so I wanted to also mention that the
classroom technology is centrally
managed on our campus which is another
important factor we manage the actual
installations and the standards for the
installations and the scheduling is also
centrally managed for all of our general
assignment classrooms which is also an
important factor in our program we have
about 12 years of course casting on the
talk specifically about web cast out
Berkeley we have about 12 years of
experience under our belt in the course
casting here arena we started as a
research organization the Berkeley
multimedia Research Center by professor
Larry row and you know we grew we grew
to become a campus service with the with
a worldwide audience and it's been
amazingly successful our approach is
focused on automated capture and
delivery systems you know we believe in
the efficiencies that we can obtain by
automating processes and and reducing
overhead we also think a lot about
trying to reduce the barriers of entry
for faculty who are participating I know
there are some programs out there
they're really great prof cast and other
programs that are using manual recording
devices we kind of had a feeling that we
didn't want the professors that are the
faculty or the lecturers have to do
anything other than just come in and
turn on the mic like they normally would
or use the installed system and the
lecture recording would automatically
start so we've had about 12 12 years
we've we do about 44 courses a semester
so it's about 88 courses a year and some
of those are podcast some of those are
podcast and webcasts some of those are
web cast only and kind of look at web
casting his video and podcasting is
audio right now because of podcasting I
traditionally think of as a download
downloadable format and currently we're
only offering the audio downloads we're
constantly looking to looking for ways
to improve our services and the
processes and find new new ways to
automate our systems and so forth and
one of the major things we really want
to do is implement an open standards
format for delivery we're currently
serving out real which is proprietary
and it really has allowed us to get get
where we've gotten but because we're so
systems oriented trying to switch gears
is a little bit trying like trying to
stop a freight train so you know it
takes a little bit of research and a lot
of time and some development to think
about how to how to switch gears and
start serving up different formats under
our current implementation though we're
keeping that in mind so we did a lot of
research on some projects or products
commercial products that are out there
thinking about how to move into the next
phase of our webcast program now it's
important to note that as a research
project or because of our research
underpinnings we actually were very
homegrown all of our systems and we did
all of our own development on the
automated systems to deliver this
content so what we were looking at some
of these products you know we realize
that that they they all met some of our
needs and none of them at all of our
needs they generally lacked a
flexibility that we we needed especially
because they were they were
proprietaries we were locked on dietary
hardware there were there were
customization issues in terms of
integration into our campus wide systems
like LDAP in the Registrar so
authenticate campus authentication and
and the Registrar runs all of our
central classroom scheduling so we
basically oh they also had substantial
cost structures which we just we felt as
a group that had been developing our own
systems to do this automatically we
weren't sure that we wanted to make that
investment and have recurring annual
licensing fees that we would have to
a when there might be some potential
that we would be able to do this
ourselves so we really were faced with
the choice between customizing our
business practices or kind of rolling
our own so to speak and all the while we
were busily launching partnerships out
in the world so we launched Apple so
Berkeley on iTunes U Apple's iTunes U we
launched that in April of 2006 and as of
now I believe we have somewhere in the
neighborhood of 2600 course lectures
maybe a little more over three semesters
so it's pretty substantial podcast
download we have a lot of vents content
there as well for people to download we
even have some campus life stuff so if
you want to watch the play you can watch
you can watch that it's really famous on
campus the play where we score a
last-second touchdown to beat Stanford
in the 80s we're we're hanging on to
hanging so these these partnerships
someone say watch your back I thought I
heard that so these pot of these
partnerships have been really really
successful we've been we've gotten a lot
of valuable visibility from the
partnerships from the news and other
institutions and we get calls all the
time asking us you know how do you how
do you do what you do and it's it's just
been great because we we really feel
connected to the educational community
and in part because of our open content
stance and I guess this is when the
planets sort of began to align for us
because of the iTunes U partnership we
had some access to inside folks at Apple
and we notice that they had put up this
slick on their website about this this
product called podcast producer and so
we we started inquiring and asking them
what is what is podcast producer
what does it do and you know we knew
that that some of those commercial
products probably weren't going to work
for us we're kind of wrapping up our
investigations I guess you could call it
and so we found out that podcast
producer is basically an enterprise
scripting framework for capturing
delivery that marries OS 10 leopard
server systems and leopard client
systems with X grid and QuickTime
technologies and when we talked to them
a little bit we immediately recognized
that there was an opportunity to
leverage the technology to develop the
next generation webcast systems
application so we basically decided that
we were going to try and do this within
the sky framework and what that means is
that podcast producer is a core
component of that and it basically runs
on Apple hardware and the there is no
additional fee for the actual server
it's a core component of there or not
for the server but for the podcast
producer it's a core component of their
operating system so we're piloting it as
a core component and we feel like this
this hybrid approach basically allows us
to focus on our specific needs at the
same time because it's within the sack
I've the Sakai framework we're keeping
our eyes on an ultimate goal of trying
to build a community around the
technology and provide provide that open
source framework that actually could
bootstrap other universities programs
for caption content and you know while
we're very systems oriented and we're
very automated oriented I know there are
other universities out there that are
much more manual and there's always the
possibility that you might be able to
take this technology and adapt it
through your own purposes so that's an
interesting development I want to talk a
little bit about just to go back to the
infrastructure
in the classrooms and centrally managed
the centrally managed equipment in the
classrooms and essentially scheduled to
put in the classroom some of the power
of being part of Sakai and having it as
part of Sakai is we have a local
instantiation of psychical be space and
they've already meted out all the
details of integrating with the ldap and
with the registrar and some of those
other really important functions of an
automated system that are going to allow
us to basically harvest some of that
data so about when the classes and and
who the professor is and what the title
is and some of those important metadata
tags that you're going to want to inject
into your contents there's a lot of
automated stuff that's going to be
happening behind the scenes there and so
right now we're at about fifty percent
installed classrooms and with projectors
and VHS and DVDs and so forth and with a
really high level commitment from our
central administration to bring that to
a hundred percent of our GA classrooms
and really have everything capable and
our plan is to have over basically any
classroom over 50 seats with installed
technology for screencasts or podcast
then we have a limited number or select
group of webcast enable or video-enabled
classrooms and it's just interesting to
note that with the media sort of the new
communication tool for lecture content
and
the know people have been talking about
Lawrence Lessig is quote about text
being dead medium although I would argue
that it's more dynamic now and not so
much dead that it's really important to
have sort of a more ubiquitous capture
environment where you can really pull
more more content and make more content
available if that truly is the medium
that students and others are capable of
communicating and that's the direction
we want to want to go and it's also a
great tool for teaching and learning
that that content and I believe that my
colleague Judy starts going to talk a
little bit about that tomorrow so
believe that's it so thank you very much